hello pilots let's discuss superiority
and battles advantage points the
important role of attack aircraft and
how concealment works let's start with
the basics
your team can achieve victory and a
standard battle either by destroying all
enemy aircraft or gaining supremacy so
what is superiority and how can you gain
it first of all you need to score
advantage points you do this by
destroying enemy targets both on the
ground and in the air one destroyed
aircraft will bring one point to your
team the same for destroying a ground
target and three points for a
headquarters at the top of the screen
you can see the so called supremacy
meter that displays each team's current
battle progress at the beginning of the
battle this bar is empty it begins to
fill after each team starts scoring
points a team that achieves 100%
superiority wins the battle if the enemy
team has more advantage points but loses
all their aircraft your team wins
regardless of the number of advantage
points the battle can come to a draw
when either the bar remains equal after
the end of the 15-minute battle or all
aircraft on both teams are destroyed if
the enemy team destroys a friendly
aircraft or ground target your team will
lose some part of the supremacy meter
filling a team loses 15% advantage if
one of their aircraft is destroyed a
destroyed ground target cost 30%
advantage a team loses 90 percent
advantage if their headquarters is
destroyed how fast the bar fills depends
on the difference in advantage points of
both teams let's look at an example
team a lost for aircraft while Team B
lost one aircraft it means that the
score is one to four team B is leading
by three points the supremacy meter of
Team B fills at 0.8% per second so team
a has about a minute and a half to score
points suppose Team a destroys a small
ground target the score is now two to
four with team be having a two-point
advantage the supremacy meter of Team B
drops by 30% and starts filling again at
0.6% per second then Team B destroys
team a's headquarters the score is now 2
to 7 and Team B has a 5 point advantage
their supremacy meter continues filling
but faster at one point 2 percent per
second
attack aircraft are very important for
cheating and maintaining advantage this
is the most controversial aircraft type
in the game attack aircraft carry
powerful weapons and have high
durability many also have a rear gunner
however their low speed and
maneuverability as well as low optimum
altitude compensate for it low optimum
altitude is both a strong and a weak
point though it's all about aircraft
concealment an aircraft flying low to
the ground is harder to detect different
aircraft types have different
concealment effectiveness attack
aircraft have the best concealment if an
aircraft flies at an altitude of 200
meters or lower they receive concealment
bonus the lower they fly the higher the
bonus is dropping bombs does not affect
concealment aircraft lose concealment
when they open fire or launch rockets
concealment begins to work again and a
few seconds after aircraft have stopped
fire if an aircraft is set on fire
flames and smoke will give it away
attack aircraft are the most effective
aircrafts type in destroying ground
targets even when using machine gun and
autocannon by the way have you noticed
that the same buildings or a a guns on
the same map may have different levels
of hit points let's find out why every
ground target type has standard
durability that increases depending on
the tier of the battle it is calculated
by a simple formula multiplied your
ability by X where X is the highest
aircraft tier in the battle let's take
an AAA gun for example if the highest
aircraft tier in the battle is tier 1
the AAA gun will have 150 hit points if
the highest aircraft's tier and the
battle is tier 10 the AAA gun will have
1500 hit points now let's move from
theory to practice here are several
examples of how to conduct battle when
the enemy team has advantage for
instance let's look at if only enemy
aircraft are left and you're flying a
fighter look for enemy aircraft while
flying at about 500 meters above the
ground most likely they'll be flying
along map borders check the area around
the enemy base but try to avoid enemy
AAA guns occasionally enemy attack
aircraft won't be too cunning you will
likely find them near your ground
targets when you get advantage enemy
aircraft will try to knock it down as
soon as an enemy attack
a friendly ground target it will be
displayed on the mini-map enemy aircraft
will be revealed so you will be able to
catch up with it and bring it down the
opposite situation you're flying an
attack aircraft while there are only
enemy fighters left you should carefully
move to the nearest enemy a a gun or
other ground target if enemy aircraft
haven't been spotted in that area if
your team has only a narrow advantage
destroy a few ground targets and quickly
fly to another area usually the speed of
your actions matters the most in this
situation destroy already damaged ground
targets ideally the damaged enemy
headquarters do 1 attack run and move to
a different area
you shouldn't simply cruise around if
both you and your enemies are flying
attack aircraft the best you can do is
to destroy ground targets while
monitoring the activity of Allied aaaa
guns on your mini-map if the enemy
suddenly stops destroying friendly
ground targets and you already have
advantage you should fly away there is
no guarantee that you bring enemy
aircrafts down what matters here is
patience if enemy aircraft keep
destroying your ground targets there's a
chance they will crash or will be
destroyed by friendly AAA guns just
don't crash yourself if the enemy team
has a fighter or a heavy fighter left it
could take too much time to find them
they may be flying at high altitude you
should destroy ground targets even if
you fly a fighter start with the ground
targets that have the least amount of
hit points
remember to monitor your mini-map and
radar enemy fighters may come back to
destroy aircraft that attack ground
targets here's another example the enemy
team has an 80% advantage none of your
allies are destroying ground targets you
spot an undamaged enemy aircraft and
realize that you don't have enough
firepower to destroy it quickly in this
case ramming is a viable option you'll
not only be able to knock down the enemy
advantage but pull a victory for your
team we hope that this information will
help you choose the right tactical
solutions stay less detectable survive
more often and get more enjoyment from
the game that's all for now good luck in
your battles
you